good morning it gets Tuesday August 10th
2015 which means that the next u.s.
presidential election is just 454 days
away
I think somewhere in the US later
tonight an egg will be fertilized and
that single cell will grow into two and
then four and then much later a baby
will be born an actual human being will
be thrust into the world for the first
time and it will cry presumably over the
state of American political discourse
take that baby which has not technically
been conceived yet will be six months
old before we elect a president Cape
will be laughing at its own farts by the
time we actually vote so hand campaign
cycles are getting longer around the
world but like in the UK people don't
start paying serious proper attention to
the election until five weeks before it
happens when the Queen dissolves
Parliament in Canada the 2015 campaign
period is 78 days among the longest in
Canadian history and not coincidentally
also the most expensive
uh-huh but what I wouldn't give for 78
days Hank Germany Italy the Netherlands
Nigeria Australia
none of these places have campaign
cycles lasting longer than a hundred
days quick primer for non-americans Neos
most states hold so-called primary
elections five to ten months before the
proper election in these primaries
Republican and Democratic voters choose
who they want to be their party's
candidate for president and then those
people face each other in the general
election in the end the whole process
takes about 23 times longer than it does
in the UK and also costs 40 times more
so that's nice how did this happen well
as with most things in American history
it used to be much worse for most of
American history the president wasn't
really elected democratically for one
thing most people couldn't vote because
most people were either women or not
white but even most white males had no
say in their party's presidential
candidates because those candidates were
chosen either by Congress or by powerful
members of the party but then more
people could vote in primary started to
gain traction and in January of 1960
John F Kennedy made history by declaring
his candidacy very early almost a full
year before the election and there's no
way Kennedy could have become president
under the old system he was too how do I
put this delicately Catholic but actual
voters liked him more than the
Democratic Party establishment did so he
became the nominee and eventually the
president and that's the argument for a
long campaign cycle it allows underdogs
to build momentum and in doing so makes
the whole process
or democratic but the length of
presidential campaigns has doubled since
Kennedy and costs have skyrocketed and I
struggle to see what we get for all that
time and money there are a lot of
serious policy discussions at this point
actual clowns are being treated as
serious contenders for the presidency
and instead of focusing on governing
people have to focus entirely on
campaigning I mean we're in the middle
of a 22-month multi-billion dollar
presidential campaign but we haven't had
a long-term bill to fund highways in
four years so yeah I'm not paying
attention to the so-called presidential
campaign at the moment now I'm not
criticizing those who do choose to care
about the u.s. presidential campaign now
there's lots of great organizing and
activism going on around the candidates
but my focus is elsewhere at the moment
it's on my kids and this great book that
I just read in the elections in Haiti
two days ago that finally occurred after
three years of delays here's my pledge I
will begin caring about the u.s.
presidential election 100 days before
the May 3rd primary here in Indiana so
if on January 23rd 2016 Donald Trump is
still a candidate for president of the
United States I will think about Donald
Trump for the first time in my life and
I will seek to understand his strengths
and weaknesses as a presidential
candidate until then I will remain
blissfully ignorant Hank I will see you
on Friday